Now that we have the basic understandings of what Chaos clothing is, how to set Chaos clothing up inside of the editor,
I'd like to talk about some Chaos clothing tips and tricks.
And the first thing I'd like to mention is the Chaos Content Examples Map,
as it offers a fantastic example of setting up Chaos clothing in so many different scenarios.
It actually first starts up with just some very, very simplistic Chaos clothing driven by the wind, which is actually what we talked about today.
And then it goes on to show you how to adjust the properties, how to set up things like Chaos clothing with collision, adding backstop,
inner penetration, and even Chaos clothing on a playable character.
So if you haven't checked this out, I highly recommend that you do give this a thorough look through as it can fill in some gaps
and let you know about all types of amazing things that Chaos clothing can do.
In particular, the example on different settings for things like burlap, silk, rubber, or heavy leather.
One of the things that people commonly run into is not using decimals far enough.
So they use maybe 0.1 instead of 0.001.
Oftentimes, the smallest values are going to give you really great results.
So instead of, again, of using 0.1 or 0.01, try going 0.0012 or 0.00123.
Remember that you can use the input boxes inside of Unreal as calculators.
So you can do something like 1500 times 0.5, and then you could add 50 or subtract 50.
So remember that if you're having problems coming up with numbers to fill in, you can always do that inside of the input box.
One of the other really interesting things that you can do with Chaos clothing is add a constant pressure to each triangle of the simulation.
This can be also modulated via the pressure paintable mask and is a way to make something look like it is inflating, like we have in this example right here.
We also have a feature called buckling that needs to have use bending elements ticked as well.
And this allows the simulated object to closely match an object in the real world, as you can see in this video right here.
So if we want to have, you know, something that is more realistic from a simulation than going on to something that is inside of the real world,
we can kind of use this buckling to bend that pre morphed object into something that will then wrap around an object inside of the world.
There's also some improvements to self collision.
There's an additional self collision resolution step available through the use self intersection parameters and self collision.
Self collision friction now has its own self collision of friction parameter.
Only thing to note is that when you are using self collisions, this can particularly affect performance, especially if you're trying to use a complex mesh.
This is where using that proxy mesh setup comes in very handy as the simpler the mesh is, the less impactful it's going to be when it comes to self collisions, resulting in not only a more efficient rendering and operation, but also a better looking cloth reaction and simulation.